where's the second draft begin
your second draft should begin
when your first draft ends and you go
off and do something else right go away
stop looking at it take your mind off of
it which I know is very very hard right
but take your mind off of it go do
something else for at least a week give
your brain an opportunity to rest
and then come back re-read it first
before you start writing because you
should be giving your own notes right
you might not know how to give notes
like a script consultant or know how to
give notes like an executive but
something in you is telling you that
something's not working right and so you
need to track what those things are so
read your script and then just kind of
start making notes for yourself about
okay this isn't clear right here or this
gets a little confusing here Etc so that
when you're going back for your revision
you can address those things if you
don't know how to do that you're
probably going to go back because you
need to do a proofreading pass you need
to do a formatting pass you might know
that you want to look at the dialogue
again and make sure that it's not as on
the nose or in some places not too long
you know and things like that so you
know not everyone goes into their second
draft with the same intention if you've
been doing this long enough then you
already know however many drafts you're
going to have so the second draft is
going to come but if you're new with
this once you've finished and you really
don't know what should happen next
that's the time when you need to get
another set of eyes on it that's the
time when you want to come to a Scripps
consultant to say hey here it is can you
tell me you know which direction I need
to go in here do I need to rewrite from
the beginning do I need to you know just
fix a few things here and there and then
now you get back into that second draft
process of addressing those notes
what do a lot of writers get wrong about
starting that second draft they don't
give it enough space yeah I would say
not giving it enough space because you
haven't given your mind an opportunity
to see it differently right that's
what's so great about having a second
pair of eyes on something right because
this person is not bringing anything
into it not the experience of it not
that one scene that you really wanted to
keep but you had to lose that person
doesn't know anything and you'd be
surprised at how much you can forget
in a week right so if you give yourself
an opportunity to come back and re-read
then you'll kind of see it differently
and a little bit more objectively even
though it's yours so I think giving that
space is necessary and then having that
second second set of eyes if you need it
even if that's someone else that you
know maybe it's a script consultant
because at least you know you'll get
clear and actionable uh um notes but
even if it's just someone that you trust
somebody who can read it and just go ah
this is how I felt or yeah you know it's
it's looking good whatever that is
getting feedback and again that's a hard
thing none of us want to be critiqued
none of us want to be told that it's
terrible you know everybody wants to be
told it's just perfect and this is great
but that's just not going to be true
even if it's a great story that's
probably going to be something that you
can tighten up so having someone again
going back to that Brain Trust You might
not be at the point where you have
Executives as your brain trust but
there's somebody or some people who you
can send your screenplay to who can be
honest with you about where to start
because I think I think by now most
writers know that writing is rewriting
but that doesn't mean they know that
there's a difference between rewriting
and revising or where they should even
start with their rewrite or with their
revision because everything should not
be a page one rewrite right you need to
know what you're going into your draft
to do right you have to have a plan for
it it might not be as big of a plan as
outlining you know like we talk when
you're going to do your first draft but
there should be a plan it shouldn't just
be oh I'm just gonna start writing from
the top again or I'm just going to start
revising from the top again you may be
revising something that doesn't need to
be revised so being able to get you know
another pair of eyes on it and making
sure you're spending time away from it
while you're getting other pairs of eyes
on it leave it alone do not keep writing
while other people are reading you could
be causing problems right that they
don't get to give you any any feedback
on because they don't see them because
you're over here still writing while
they're doing this right or you could be
removing something that works really
well you know what I mean Let It Go step
away from it and give your or give
either yourself time to look at it from
a different perspective or give the
other person time to send it back to you
with the feedback so that you can kind
of know where to start
how does a writer know what is wrong
with their first draft yeah
that's a good question I think if you
haven't been doing this very long you
might not know right which is why you
need your brain trust or you need a
script consultant or someone who can
come in and kind of look at it to guide
you if you've been learning screenplay
structure
you might be able to say
feel like something's supposed to happen
right here and I just don't know what it
is and now again you've got to reach out
to somebody who can help you figure out
what that thing is that you're missing
hopefully most people who are choosing
to write have a natural sense of
Storytelling if you have a natural sense
of Storytelling something is doing this
to you to go this something right here
you might not be able to put your hand
on it because you're a newer writer
right and that's why you want somebody
else to take a look at it if you've been
doing this often enough then you already
know so for example I was working on
this screenplay and I was doing all of
my pre-work right like my uh character
building and uh understanding their
goals Etc before I get to my outline Etc
I never continued mostly because I got
busy but because I under already
understood that there was a problem and
I hadn't fixed it yet and the problem
was she was going to be unlikable
I wanted her to not be what we view
women to be you know I didn't want her
to be happy she's been through some
stuff she's not happy but even in her
not being happy people have to want to
root for her so she's got to be
likable in some way and I hadn't at that
time figured out how to make her likable
so I didn't bother to start reading the
screen writing the screenplay now I'm
not saying that's what everybody else
should do you know you can go ahead and
write it and then go back in and try to
make her likable but because I already
understood it to be a problem because I
know that you have to like or relate
right and you know for her I felt like
she wasn't going to be likable or
relatable because I was making her in a
way that people feel women don't show up
as so for an example she has a great
husband
great but for her he's annoying right
and so many women will say you've got a
good man then you should be X Y and Z
but for her because of her trauma which
has nothing to do with him she cannot
accept him in that way
that's not something that's in
quotations relatable because we don't
talk about that often enough might be a
lot of women who are going through it
but we don't necessarily talk about it
right and so since we don't talk about
it now we just see a woman who's being
mean to a very very nice man are we
going to want to root for her you know
what I mean maybe maybe not so because
that was something I already understood
I knew not to go forward
um and you know maybe one day I'll have
time and I can go back and I can figure
out how to make her likable you know
with other things but I think if you
really understand all of the little
elements along the way and you've done
the pre-work you know along the way then
you'll start to know I didn't quite
figure this this part out like I know
that this is conflict but I'm not really
sure if it's working I know I've got a
climax but I'm not really sure if it's
big enough or if it's Landing you know
what I mean you'll kind of feel those
things even if you don't have the uh the
vocabulary or the words to kind of talk
about it and express it which is why
again get that Brain Trust get that
writer's group get your script consoles
and get somebody else who can do that
part for you so that you can you know at
least open the door or for understanding
for the next time around
how focused on page count should new
writers be for the second draft Yeah so
I think it depends on what it is if it's
a feature page count matters for genre
right horror stories are usually not
very long they're usually going to be in
the 80 90 less than 100 kind of range if
you're doing a drama it's probably going
to be around 120 Pages or so if you're
doing a biopic it might be 130 pages
because you're talking about in a
person's entire life right so I think
it's not about writing to the page count
but it is about understanding the genre
in which you're writing right because no
one's watching a three-hour romantic
comedy you know what I mean so it's like
for you to understand the genre that
you're writing and kind of live within
that space because again people want to
show up to something that they
understand right like if I'm going to a
Marvel film if I'm going to Avatar I
might understand that I'm going to be in
here for a long time right but if I
think that I'm just going to go watch
you know guess who's coming to dinner
then I'm not trying to be in here for
you know for three hours to do that so
understanding the rules of your of your
genre is going to help with page count
when it comes to television on the other
hand it's about where you're submitting
where you're submitting to so for the
most part if you're writing a TV script
and you're a new writer you're nine
times out of ten not pitching it
anywhere because you don't have that
relationship yet that we talked about
right you don't have that agent that
manager that lawyer or whoever that's
going to connect you to the executive to
be able to pitch it in the first place
so nine times out of ten it's a writing
sample whether you want it to be that or
not that's what it is right nine times
out of ten it's not going to be picked
up to be a pilot today maybe later on in
life after you've gotten a little bit
more established maybe you might be the
one percent that did get picked up like
pose did right before the most part it's
it's probably just going to be a writing
sample that's a stepping stone to get
you to where you want to be if you're
now submitting it to fellowships or
you're submitting it to screenplay
competitions most of the time they will
give you a page count therefore you need
to be writing towards it because if not
you're going to be disqualified right so
if it said 60 page and you send in 61
you're out so you need to be writing to
60. if you get to the point where you
are
um
being able to submit to Studios networks
Etc then going back to that homework
about that brand right how many
screenplays have you read from that
Network how many
um how often have you watched the
episode and kind of paid attention to
the time right because if it's on a
streamer one episode could be 30 minutes
the next one's 45 minutes the next one's
blah blah so maybe it doesn't matter how
long your screenplay is but if you're
watching HBO it might be Clockwork 59
minutes which means you're probably not
going to have more than 65 pages so you
want to stay in that so it just depends
on what you're going to do with it now
with that being said I'm not necessarily
saying that second drafts are about page
count because if you have other problems
page count is the least of your worries
right I always tell people put it all on
the page you can always trim it later
always right so you might not start
trimming until you get to
draft five or draft 10 depending upon
how long it's taking you to get what you
need right but if you are
um in a place where you understand what
your problems are and you're able to fix
those problems then I would say second
draft is about fixing problems right and
you want to fix problems until you get
those problems fixed and then you want
to worry about page count because if you
need to trim then you're going to have
to you know everything affects
everything right so if you need to trim
you taking one piece out of a
conversation might change how your
character reacts to the other person
because again if the character was
saying curse word and now suddenly that
curse word is not in there and let's say
it's back to the daughter cursing the
mom right if the daughter curses the mom
the mom's going to respond a particular
way if somehow some way due to page
count you cut out that part mom's not
responding that same way and now there's
a trickle you know trickle-down effect
so uh trimming can um can change the
context of of what your screenplay is so
you will definitely need a draft that is
about trimming but it might not be be
your second draft
so first draft is creating problems
second draft is fixing them fixing them
third draft is problems are solved or
not always oh yeah not always oh okay
not always but hopefully you know
hopefully but not always